bri always wonders how to mom's juggle
and I think there are a ton of moms in
America that do it great I hope to do
just as well as them I'm just adding a
little dance on top of it just a little
ginger Zee has joined Dancing with the
Stars ET brought you the news first as
we were on set of good morning america
right after the official announcement
was made I think she's super capable and
really you know mentally ready for the
challenge and the doctor gave me the
go-ahead so we're safe ginger gave birth
in December to her son Adrian and will
have to travel back and forth from New
York to LA I think any mother would go
through when they go back to work it's
already difficult of course taking a
trip even as quick as it can be is going
to be tough i'm just gonna make the best
of it and make it a quick trip get right
back to my baby and even if i come in
the middle of the night i'm totally
waking him up kiss him and yep there is
a slight incentive to do all this
dancing working on her post-baby bod it
doesn't hurt it doesn't hurt that I just
better get a little it's gonna suck it
right back in of course that wasn't the
first reason because I just love the
show and but yeah of course I mean it
doesn't hurt and what new mom wouldn't
want a little help